I want to talk about the story work it's
really really weird this is a sign this
the story right here is a sign to me of
the uh of the collapse it's a very slow
collapse the first thing I'll say all
right I'll give you I'll give you the
story Boston Pride
LGBT Pride dissolves amid diversity
complaints an organization that's been
around for 50 years to advocate for LGBT
rights has dissolved because well black
lives matter activists said that they
didn't have enough diversity on their
board now I want to mention something I
say it's a slow collapse right
we went to a diner today to pick up some
petty melts we got everybody these
burgers are so good oh they were good
they were they were delicious and a
peanut butter pie and there's a sign on
the door and this this shocked me it
said for it's something like forgive us
from now on we'll be operating only 6
a.m to 5 p.m as we attempt to rectify
our staffing shortages half the diner
was closed like they had the signs up
like you can't sit here and they were
completely understaffed and they a diner
that closes at 5 PM nothing to do with
pride or whatever but it's just like
the food shortages the chaos yeah the
unemployment stuff it's just getting
worse and worse and worse we'll come
back to that I just want to mention as
part of the slow collapse but look at
this story they say this decision was
made with a heavy heart out of love and
hope for a better future the
organization's board sending a statement
Boston Pride the organization that has
organized the city's Pride celebrations
for 50 years has announced it's shutting
down
the dissolution announced Friday
afternoon in a statement on the group's
website comes after the reportedly
all-white board of directors had faced
ongoing accusations of ignoring racial
minorities and transgender people it is
clear to us that our community needs and
wants change without the involvement of
Boston Pride
here's what here's the quote We Have
Heard
I'm going to read the quote okay we have
heard the concerns of the
qtbipoc community what and others the
statement continued I I don't know what
that means and I'm not trying to be mean
to the
quit the puck
oh cute bipod is that what it's supposed
to be I don't I don't I don't I don't
look these people are increasingly
there was a video I saw of this like
young woman and she was it's a it's a
viral Tick Tock where she's like you can
use new words for your non-binary
parents like zizo and zorbeda I'm not
kidding she was like pom pom Pina dophi
and I'm like you're just saying
gibberish words what are you doing
that's where we're at right now these
young people are like I can make up a
thing and so they make up a thing and
then the people who make up a thing go
to the established thing and say you
have to shut down because we made a
thing up and they go okay and then it
shuts down how do we function as a
society look I'm sure there's a bunch of
conservatives you know cracking cigars
and laughing you know watching this but
I'm like
Boston Pride 50 years of fighting for
LGBT rights and quite successfully and
now they're shut down just like that
it's like Occupy Wall Street that was my
experience at occupy went and I brought
the Constitution I was like yo I'm going
to tell people about the Federal Reserve
this isn't a rally of troops and when I
went up the girl was like I was gonna go
speak to them to like some news
organization and the girl was like no
we've already had too many white people
speak to the news I was like what I'm
about to blow people's minds dude let me
add it and they wouldn't so I was like
well too much too much racism for good
stuff at the top I you know it's just
it's just demands for Power Man
long live the Ron Paul Revolution that's
what we're up to man repeal the Federal
Reserve Act of 1913.
um for the polarization among the left
is ridiculous their their desired a
fraction off into little pieces it's
crazy especially because I always
thought and I could be wrong about this
but I'm gonna pretend like it's
authoritative uh the rainbow flag was
like all colors can be uh within the
LGBT community if that's not real it
sounds like it makes sense and they
should adopt that but yeah
um there's a desire among lefties to do
what I think Thomas refers to as like
mascotism like they want to have black
mascots right that aren't necessary like
they don't necessarily have anything to
do with the organization but as long as
they're there and it looks nice and it's
weirdly to give the illusion of fighting
racism but in reality there's like
nothing more racist than like I want a
black logo tokenism yeah so that you can
you can uh you know think I'm virtuous
you know I I will say I'm actually
surprised they did this but they did add
a white stripe to the to the new to the
new uh LGBT flag so but what is the
white stripe for though white people
really
I would doubt I would doubt though I
mean I look at a flag that's got a black
and a brown stripe for black and brown
people and there's a white stripe and
then a yellow triangle the only thing I
can say is if they say the stripes
represent the color of the people well
it's a white stripe I was either they're
like life is not black and white and you
know that flag is copyrighted right that
new one really yeah that's owned by
somebody you mean the one with the the
purple circle in it uh I don't know if
it's a circle but it's like the one with
the the black and brown with the diamond
it looks like the Ripoff yeah yeah I
think my biggest problem is the level of
intelligence of the people that we're
talking about because people are not
black and white at all and we never have
been but the people are just accepting
these dumb phrases of black and white
and then they're saying it anyway is
concerning to me my favorite thing about
the whole critical race Theory stuff the
the critical race applied principles is
that they're like whiteness doesn't mean
white people we're not saying it's
whiteness it's a structure of of the
system black and brown means literally
the color of your skin it's like
black there's no black skin that's like
apparently they mean white people when
they're saying whiteness well it's it
you always got to like get these people
and ask them okay what's the difference
between a white supremacist nation and a
white majority Nation like they won't be
able to tell you and I didn't think of
that I got that question from Devin
Tracy well here's a question what's the
difference between a white supremacist
nation and a Chinese majority Nation
what they would be because really
Chinese supremacist well exactly like
but they would say whiteness they would
say oh well I kid you not they would say
something like well because the Chinese
population is the majority in China
they're white
I mean they think Asian people are white
anyway so but yeah but I I will say it's
just
this this this flag in my opinion
represents that
there was no committee vote on this it
was like someone did it and it was a
meme and that shows that a lot of what's
happening on the left is basically I
view it as kind of like the oh you ever
see that horror movie The Blob
yeah yeah a long time ago which one uh
there was one it was like in the 80s I
think that's the one yeah Carpenters
yeah like it lands in the meteor or
something yeah and then it's like it's
small but then it eats some something uh
wrote it then it grows a little bigger
nightmares that's exactly what it is
right that's what the left is doing
right now it's just absorbing
institutions and then growing bigger but
it's nonsensical it's just a heaping
mess you can see it it's nondescript and
it's insane
then it's ripping itself well it's
ripping everything apart it's just
destroying things and it's based on
nonsense like the the whole thing about
black Trans women being killed more uh
my friend Nuance board did a video on
this and he found that black Trans women
have a lower rate of death by homicide
than regular uh black men like so
biological males that just identify as
male well yeah yeah over explaining that
you did a good job so so I want to I
want to just kind of wrap this into the
conversation we're you know at large is
that we're talking about we start off
talking about the balkanization of this
country why is it possible in my opinion
that we're heading towards this because
this stuff makes no sense Boston Pride
shuts down because black lives matter
accuse them of not having enough
diversity so they just shut down their
civil rights organization after 50 years
just like that bro if it's that easy to
dissolve an organization and we're at
you know a roughly 35 percent probably
not a fair number but you know the best
number we got
how do you how hard do you think it's
really going to be to dissolve these
bonds they did that on Toronto remember
too a couple years ago they sat down in
front of them right and then they gave
them a list of Demands where I come from
that's called taking hostages they had a
huge acronym that I tried I was trying
to read I'm not kidding it was like
um it was like QT II three nine like I'm
I'm not trying to be mean I'm like
literally number two in it too yeah yeah
but no no I'm not so there's lgbtq I I
uh lgbtq
iap2a yeah there's a plus no but there's
another one which is a reference to
marginalized people not uh like the LGBT
one is a reference to like gender
identities and sexuality and the other
one is based on racial identities and
you know racial and culture so that one
is like
you know you know they do like
um what is it uh Asian Pacific Islander
whatever it's called API or whatever API
or whatever yeah there was one like that
and it was like aapi T3
s2911 that's like a robot's name T2 was
a way better movie than T3 I'm just
throwing out that controversial opinion
no no but it is it gets crazy my
favorite one that's included in there
isn't the two spirit it's the second a
for Ally it's like what that's just yeah
there's one of them is Ally so if you're
a straight and a straight yeah a
straight A straight and a CIS
heteronormative oh I was thinking about
c as in trans there's trans the Romans
had trans Alpine Gall and CIS Alpine
Gall I don't know if this relevant trans
and says are means Beyond and nearer too
literally why they say you're a CIS
person or a trans person they say is a
reference to like I'm glad that you know
that I got that out but like if you're
straight then like you get to be in the
in the acronym and it's like dude that's
not for you just stop go get out of
there
stripe to the flag
we still don't know what it's for it
doesn't matter what they say it's for if
the black and brown represent black and
brown people the white stripe represents
white people is the white stripe
underneath the black and brown stripe no
it's underneath the blue and
Periwinkle strike that made sense look
at this picture what is this called that
may be white I just like that LGBT if
it's above it I'm just gonna say that um
well it is the first stripe racism yeah
the whites are going to be asexual
no the um isn't that what the yellow is
for
eign
I think they're missing the point of
white I was gonna say Pikachu like the
Pokemon when I so my family had a cafe
in uh on North Halsted in Chicago which
is like this it's Boys Town it's the gay
neighborhood and then there's
um the one where Jesse smaller was
attacked no no he wasn't there he was in
uh he was in downtown okay North Halsted
is several miles north it's um it's like
it's by Wrigley Field and then there's
there's Boys Town in ladies town and I
forgot what ladies Town's actual name is
but that's where the lesbians are at and
then the gay men are in in Boys Town but
I was told uh when I was there that the
flag represented the different aspects
of the of the gay community not races or
anything like that I don't know for sure
though but it's weird to see that they
added race too yeah I thought it was
just like flamboyant colors that they
liked wearing no there's a color they
represent something they represent some
things I thought it was them being extra
because normally one cause one color and
they're like we want all the colors
deal with gray if you want to be opposed
to us I don't like the whites on there
because when you look at a rainbow all
the colors it's white light and only if
you look at it through a prism do you
start to see all the colors of the
rainbow which is the flag is the colors
of the rainbow so when they combined all
of the lantern rings they created the
White Lantern corn there we go
I'm just saying like the new flag's got
a white stripe in it now I think of
myself as an ally I think of myself as
like an Allied to people in general to
these people of all kinds but I don't
virtue signal would you Ally with The
Blob
The Blob consumes a Krispy Kreme I think
that would be and you like Krispy Kreme
and you're like I'm a fan of The Blob
because it consumed Christmas it's a
game time decision because if if no I
probably wouldn't allow with The Blob
that's what I'm trying to say
um I believe in civil rights I'm fairly
I'm I'm actually fairly um moderately
left on a lot of the social justice
causes but when you have a blob that
consumes institutions I'm not going to
pretend The Blob represents the blob is
full of people so you can you know they
dissolve interact with those people well
I I would say you can't use their
language like the the reason they use
the term like social justice and which
is why I named my channel to be the
opposite of that is because it's like oh
I'm not against societal progress and
justice but like once we start adopting
their language it doesn't work I agree
with you I'm like in terms of social
issues I'm really libertarian but like
we CA we can't use their terms yeah yeah
no that's that's absolutely so so just
to simplify when the blob when I see
like you know an LGBT LGBT you know uh
Pride campaign or something or Boston
Pride and they're like we believe that
we should have the right to to live
freely and be in our homes and I'm like
I hear you man then a blob consumes them
and then the blob like a face comes out
of the Flesh of The Blob but it's like
just like a flat blob face when I
believe in words I'm like that's not
Boston Pride that's something else I
knew you once yeah remember no longer
have you ever seen uh The Frighteners oh
with um Michael uh Michael J fox nope
I've heard of it though there's like the
the walls like it's like someone's
pushing out through like latex that's
what it looks like that's what it would
be like when the when the when the blob
is rolling by and then you see like you
know a civil rights activist come on go
support they can be exercised from The
Blob it just takes strategic uh surgery
mental surgery it it's also weird how
these movements kind of imitate real
life because there is more homophobia
among like the black community in the
United States of America on average
obviously there's pockets of like you
know Evangelical Christians or or
actually Mormons are nice to everybody
they just want to play board games with
you but there's like pockets of it so
like for a like supposed black civil
rights movement to bully out of
existence a gay civil rights movement
it's really like it's it's like almost
like the movements are imitating their
uh their base thanks for checking out
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and soon
Super Chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time